[музика]
такому хаосу sparky не їм підпорядковані
побачиш
за про купання на тротуарі t5
паркування за барона на штраф 15-ті ну що
це тампон від року на 25 гру історію
це шляхом упирі skoda 35 євро це вище
мінімальний штраф за неправильно парку
ванням німецька система паркування
просто відразу мило те
ефективно і найкраще і спосіб
продемонструвати це парк уват осі ми
ви пробуємо aussi назвав і не способи та
Розкажемо про стіни до яких я їх не
порушення
спасибі піші б із кущів на парк біля вані
вже нових районах часто можна
паркуватися себе з кущів ну а ви тут я
свої правила і надій промивання дослівно
вище для мішкан серединку квітки видними
при свічці ним та штрафу 10 євро можна
вранці цієї та за проживання на двох
місцях за місяць по іншому настя
німецьку починку наприклад публіку
парку так вже й потрібні гості вас
культурного паркування
будемо такі знак і утримуватимемо участю в
даному на жаль катування додзвону безкоштовно
стоять іспано delco до суботи проти вас
3 роки за допомогою всього парку вільного
води на кому і в казим і годині я кай
завищуємо в оптику
я все вініл же 5 літровим схил штраф
гарантовано спасибі інше платний
парку ванням припаркувався завантажую
центрі місця найпростіша вони чекають кущів
ну алана вид на платних парковках та
наділи води ті кружляють і дуг вибачитися
місця для кіш на стоянці зайчика потрібно
плати то я автомат у їдкій Москві та йому
монетки на табло висвічується
проплачений час друг сила-силенна талончик
ленка що я середньому
адже ти фтору до 3 євро за роки, але їх
зараз вийшов і вийшовши з [ __ ] все на 30
квіллінг штраф 10 євро і ок чон а над
3 худі на 30 євро душу дбайливо в роті
паркувалися а повезу liqueur in the
пожежній встаньте і легше автомобіль
стрибка чаю виїзду жарт та чиї пожежника
авто заплатіть за це міста типу ніч з
10 євро та то ваш автомобіль шви че за
всі його палити і turbo видати з правдиві
труси таємниця монет за брата машин або
штрафного майдан чека переконатися у
середньому вбити 200 до пана 300 євро
робиш на вигляд місця на і дуріти
ставив не вул ambrose лікаря самої мети
100 забрав рекорди хитрує штрафи за
неправильне паркування
17 мільйонів у гру за 2000 15 рік
пробачиш алей знайду рушницю про когось
убити земних парковках я київ кожному ви
лакум разом у них маже завжди і вели
настя
рот шинка європейських підземних парковок
спеціальної паркували місця для виділів
щеня праворуч у тому всі п'ять за не
паркування досить ти мені порожнім її
щеням надається правового паркування
було ще до виїзду щось приборкаю освітлених
місцях відомо жженова посвяти
проти чого цуценя за висота пе-2 трави
мск лом непотрібно і ces правді функцію
але й людині він ікають паркування тут
теж головне у німецькому складі парку
ваніні штрафи
а культура вийде